perhaps we could reach as high as 50 75
with all due respect mr. Bracken this is
not a negotiation it's definitely a
negotiation
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school I knew from
a very early age that I wanted to be a
lawyer and not just any lawyer a trial
lawyer and I learned that by watching
lawyers on TV now having been a trial
attorney for over 10 years now I see
that some shows are more realistic than
others so I thought I'd take some time
to review some of the most famous legal
scenes from TV history the first scene
comes from the show Ally McBeal
well as I said her arm brushed mine and
when she brushes an arm it's with sexual
intent objection just tell us what
happened at but she brushed your arm sir
so that's actually a really good
objection the kind of objection that you
would see in most trials the witness
here is testifying to things that he has
no personal knowledge of which is
specifically what the mental impressions
are of another person you can't testify
as to what another person is thinking so
the objection that's being made was
correct and the judge was right to
sustain it they didn't actually say
objection lack of personal knowledge or
speculation but the judge understood
that made the right call well I looked
at her there was I was feeling a little
chemistry she then brought her hand to
my Maya so that's a good recovery by
this witness the judge sustained the
objection to essentially speculation and
the witness then proceeds to talk about
only those things that he personally
observed and he testifies to two things
one as to his own internal state of mind
which he's allowed to testify to and he
also testifies as to physical acts that
he actually watched he was a percipient
witness to an expert can opine about
things that are outside of their
personal knowledge but a lay witness
like most witnesses can only testify to
the things that they have seen or heard
or personally witnessed so that's what
this witness is doing here
growing area she began to fondle me a
little and so sometimes there are
outbursts in court that's not
particularly unusual I think the the
screeching that the attorney has done
here is a little bit unusual and is
really bad for his client so he would be
better served by keeping his mouth shut
and not screeching in a way that
prejudice is his client potentially
that's a prejudicial act to his client
which you know sometimes you can't
control things and you know things
happen but being professional in court
is a very important thing you don't want
to lose credibility in front of the
judge or the jury and while that
particular Yelp was probably unrealistic
what is actually more realistic about
this show compared to most is that the
lawyers are not running around the well
of the court the the area between the
judge and counsel table like they own
the place it appears that the attorney
who is asking questions is right in
front of counsel table and usually if if
you're conducting an examination you're
not gonna be right up against the
witness
you're not gonna pacing up and down the
well you're going to be either at
counsel table or you're gonna be behind
it and here it appears that the attorney
is just in front of counsel table which
is usually allowed you have to ask
permission of the judge if you are going
to enter the well but they're not doing
something that's crazy like running
around yelling like you'll see in a lot
of procedural dramas so that part is
actually realistic the Yelp is probably
not not so realistic the next scene is
from Boston Legal routinely go to church
on Sundays and ceremoniously eat the
body of Christ drink his blood he who
eats my flesh and drinks my blood abides
in me and I in him Jesus said that how
dare you what who have I offended now oh
yeah you take a holy sacrament literally
is that not done you have equated it
with the final and despicable actor okay
so here a couple things are going on
appears that the attorney is giving a
closing argument about a client who has
conducted an active cannibalism and he
is defending that by saying that there
are other religious orders that conduct
an act that is similar to cannibalism
the judge here has done essentially the
the worst thing you can do as a judge
which is to opine personally against
another attorney so he's taken offense
it's something that the attorney has
said he is not making a legal argument
he is simply just issuing his own
personal thoughts about what is or is
not allowable according to the the
scripture that is that's the worst thing
a judge can do a judge is supposed to be
impartial and if you have lost your
impartiality and it's clear to the jury
that you are are no longer impartial
then it's your duty as a judge probably
to declare a mistrial and potentially
there could be some professional
responsibility actions taken against the
judge because he's shown that he cannot
be impartial the next step that that I
would do if I was an attorney is move to
dismiss the judge for being prejudiced
and I would use the record of the court
to show this lack of impartiality
potentially that's the the plan that
this attorney has done is to show that
the judge is not being impartial and
trying to get some favor from the jury
but a long standing judge as it appears
this judge would be would never make
these sort of statements and if they did
they could be removed from the office
I apologize Your Honor I certainly don't
mean to indict Holy Communion but let's
not carry on with the idea that the
notion of cannibalism offends the
sanctity of life it has roots not only
in sacraments not to be taken literally
but also Greek mythology it's still
glorified in certain sections of both
the south and I believe Malibu and I
might add it's not illegal so the the
lawyer here is making an impassioned
plea which you're allowed to do to the
jury but in so doing it sounds like he's
bringing in a lot of facts and figures
that almost certainly did not come out
in trial and it's really important for
the jury only two to use facts that came
out in trial to base their decision and
and all of these these statistics it's
possible that the that the lawyer
brought them in through a process called
judicial notice which is that sometimes
there are statistics that are so
incontrovertible that the court will
just allow them to be brought into court
without showing an underlying basis for
example if you were going to say that a
certain date occurred on a certain day
like Monday Tuesday Wednesday you could
show that on a calendar and and that
fact would be so incontrovertible that
you're allowed to bring that in these
statistics about cannibalism and about
the the notion of who and who is not
cared for by the government that seems
like a pretty far stretch and it would
be improper for him to cloud the record
with these extrinsic facts that did not
come out the next scene comes from LA
law UCLA Harvard Law who UC editor of
the Law Review aims competition best
oralist so the aims competition is a
real-life competition at Harvard Law
that is for
moot court and they're saying that this
person won best oralist at the Moot
Court Competition moot Court is where
attorneys pretend to be appellate
attorneys not trial attorneys and they
handle a fake appellate court case in
front of a panel of judges and the aims
Moot Court Competition is very famous
they are so famous in fact that they
often get Supreme Court judges to judge
the the competitors so that's a fun
real-life fact that they threw in there
I am impressed mr. Rollins thank you sir
a attorney could often be impressed by
that resume he went to UCLA for
undergrad Harvard Law School won the
Moot Court Competition and he's now
interviewing for a job in Los Angeles
that's not a bad resume to bring in
there I was so good about yourself well
let's see my my mother's an attorney my
father's a professor of economics at UC
Riverside
I've clerked for the past few summers at
Felder IV McCoy as a matter of fact they
offered me a permanent position but
under the heading less is more I think
that a small prestigious firms such as
Mackenzie Brockman could be more
responsive my personal needs
or at least bill Howard thing that's
really interesting so that is a very
realistic way of going about getting a
job in law school this seems to be a
recent graduate from Harvard Law School
he said he clerked for a few years at a
law firm that I don't think the law firm
is real but often the way you get a job
in law school is you clerk it's called a
summer associate ship with a law firm
and if you do a good job in your 2l
summer then they will often offer you a
job
upon graduation and what this young man
is saying he's doing is he doesn't want
to work for this big prestigious law
firm instead he wants to come out and
interview with this boutique law firm
because it suits his whatever it is that
he's looking for in Los Angeles so so
far a pretty realistic reason for this
young man to apply for a job at this
this law firm so far so good at least no
Howard think so
bill Howard as in Howard enterprises yes
sir he's been a close personal friend of
my family years oh boy um I don't think
it's particularly realistic to drop
names in the interview that might go
unsaid but to bring it up and and to
boast about your family connections in
the middle of the interview that's not
that's not a good form it happens it
probably happens more often than it
should I mean people probably are better
served by getting in through merit than
connections but you know sometimes
family connections matter it's it's a
it's a part of the world
thank you what would you be looking for
in the way of compensation seventy two
five and I wouldn't be opposed to your
designating a percentage of that as a
signing bonus
excuse me but we've been starting our
associates pretty much commensurate with
the going rate which as I'm sure you're
aware is considerably lower I understand
sir but I've already been offered 71
with Horton gold so much for your
doctrine of less is more sometimes more
is more this is really interesting it's
not often that junior associates
bargained so hard for their salary but
what he's saying is that the firm that
he was a summer associate at and he he
clerked there has already given him a
job offer which is normal he spent his
summer there and they gave him an offer
upon graduation and he's trying to
leverage that to get a better salary at
this law firm and most law firms do
actually adhere to sort of a standard
rate this is in the early early 90s or
the late 80s and they're talking about
salaries of $70,000 or more that that
seems about right for the time these
days graduates from prestigious law
firms going into the top-notch law firms
are likely to get a salary of between
160 and 190 thousand dollars per year
and they're sort of a standard scale
that is applied and most law firms say
they are lockstep so you don't have any
bargaining power they pay all first-year
associates X amount between 160 190 and
he's trying to do his best to to get
even more out of this firm so good for
him I I wish it was possible for more
law students to bargain more but but
sadly most law firms are lockstep and
not a lot of bargaining power there well
perhaps we could reach as high as 50 75
with all due respect mr. Bracken this is
not a negotiation it's definitely a
negotiation gentlemen it's been a
genuine honor and a pleasure thank you
very much he's a winner I want him to be
our winner I strongly disagree I'm on
pulling rank Douglas what are you gonna
do when his salary becomes common
knowledge among the other associates
we'll see that it doesn't ooh
that's true because law firms ostensibly
pay first-year associates all the same
if it became public knowledge that one
associate was paid significantly more
than the rest that would cause some
dissent the next clip comes from Boston
Legal
value of human life it's a bugger my
friend Jerry Spence tells a story of
this paperboy delivering his papers on
this morning route 1 Dave throws the
paper through the windows shatters the
class lines a woman what's the value of
that hmm paperboy decides to give the
woman his profits for the week not very
much considering she's blinded now here
we have a loss of life an avoidable loss
not merely an accident one they could
have prevented well I think that
paperboy the right idea
at the end of this trial I'm gonna get
up I'm gonna ask the defendant to pay my
client one week's profit now let's make
that a day's profit let's not get greedy
here we may not be able to put a price
on Mary affinities life but we can at
least pay your family the profits for
the day they killed her so there's a
couple things going on here which are
pretty interesting number one is that
there are almost always two phases two
major personal injury cases sometimes
they are tried together sometimes they
are tried separately and they're their
reasons for that and and the two things
that you have to show is liability which
means that the defendant is responsible
for the injuries of the plaintiff but
then separate from that is how much
compensation should the defendant pay
the plaintiff if they are liable and
those are often called liability versus
compensation so here the attorney is
pretty confident or that perhaps they've
already established liability and so
they're simply going to the damages
portion of the trial and and what he's
hinting at is how do you compensate a
plaintiff for the injury that they have
received and in the law there are two
ways of going about it one is pure
compensation for the injuries so however
much you are injured you're gonna get a
monetary sum that is equal to that
but if the defendants actions are so
egregious that they warrant punishment
it's rare in civil cases but sometimes
you're allowed what are called punitive
damages and that's what William Shatner
here is hinting at he's saying that as a
punitive measure the defendant should be
required to disgorge a single day's
profit for the injuries that they caused
and I don't know what what law is being
broken here that would allow him to get
punitive damages punitive damages are
somewhat rare they require they usually
require some sort of egregious conduct
but if you are allowed unitive damages
sometimes they're set by law and
sometimes they are just simply a
fraction that's set by the judge of the
jury of the worth of the defendant or
sometimes even the profit that they
would have received in a day or a month
or a year
it's the punitive damages should be
large enough to punish the defendant so
if you're dealing with a really wealthy
defendant then it needs to be large
enough to punish them for them because
sometimes if you have what would seem
like a large amount if you're dealing
with a multi-billion dollar corporation
it doesn't really punish them in a way
that they're going to take notice so
that's what William Shatner is going
after here a day's profit to really make
them feel the pain that they inflicted
on the plaintiff here what could be more
fair than that what could be more fair
so hmm
my clients profits are not relevant the
number of stores they have is not
relevant how dare you go into that and
how dare you not shut him down so
whether or not the the defendants
profits are relevant would be decided
long before they get to trial there
would be motions that would lay the
foundation for why corporations profits
are relevant to punitive damage there
would be a
two of pretrial motions to decide
whether or not the prophets and the
punitive damages of a company are
relevant to the case or not if indeed
there has been no motion for that and
there's been no back and forth between
the attorneys and the judge then it
would have been incredibly improper for
William Shatner to bring that up in
front of the jury potentially even
leading to a mistrial but what TV shows
often get wrong is the mountain of
paperwork that happens before trial all
of these decisions all these legal
questions are settled long before you
get to court they would not have a
sidebar like what's going on here
to decide in the middle of trial whether
he's allowed to make these arguments or
not that's totally unrealistic may I go
off the record briefly all right head
thank you this is not for your ears by
the way you stupid bastard cases rarely
turn on what's legally relevant but you
have to be concerned with here is it all
shop makes a hundred and sixty million
dollars of pure profit a day a day the
jury will get wind of those numbers in
which case will appeal great do you
think you'll be the lawyers to handle
that appeal when your client gets
whacked with a fifty million dollar
judgment you're an ass you're an ass
you're yes so a couple things going on
here he's basically admitted that the
profits of the defendant are not
relevant not something you want to do if
you are trying to get those profits in
in front of a jury probably not a good
idea to admit to the judge that the
they're not relevant because the judge
has a duty to make sure that no
irrelevant evidence comes before the the
jury William Shatner does hint at
something that is often the case which
is that the same lawyers that tried the
case are rarely the ones to take the
appeal sometimes they do sometimes they
don't there are specialists who handle
the appeal but the opposing attorney is
absolutely right that if he brings in
these prejudicial facts against the will
of the court then he has a dead winner
on appeal or at least he should now
whether they're going to want to go
through the
the cost of going through another trial
again after the appeal that's a bigger
question but it sounds like a big
company and they may want to go through
all that again on the idea that the
plaintiffs attorneys won't want to go
through the trial one more time and and
potentially lose so some of that is
realistic but this whole monologue in
front of the judge that that is not
going to happen the next clip comes from
Rick and Morty you are about to enter
the courtroom of Judge Morty Durham jr.
the people are real the cases are real
the rulings are final
this is his courtroom this is judge
Morty 60 year old inmate Rick Allen is
being accused of committing murder of a
fellow inmate at Georgia Penitentiary
mr. Allen claims that he is being set up
and that his lawyer is requesting sexual
favors in exchange for proper legal
advice okay okay mr. mr. Allen right I
believe that I believe that your case is
was going to be going to trial not this
Monday but the following Monday do you
understand that yes okay I tell you if
you need to tell me something I want
I'll let you come up here to the podium
so you can speak into the microphone so
my understanding is that this clip is
actually a real-life transcript that
happened in a criminal proceeding that
the the makers of Rick and Morty then
set to the voices of Rick and Morty and
animated it and it really sounds like
the some of the crazy stuff that can
happen in criminal proceedings what's
happening here is not uncommon often the
defendant will not be happy with his
publicly appointed attorney and he or
she will request that that attorney be
either substituted or that the defendant
is allowed to just handle things on
their own and that's the thing that
happens it's called representing
yourself pro se when you represent
yourself and there's an old adage that
anyone who represents himself has a full
for a client and the judges don't like
it
you're not generally gonna do a very
good job even if you've been trained as
an attorney which most people have not
but judges hate it because it slows
things down they really have to hold the
hands of the defendants who represent
themselves and it can really just muck
things up which I'm guessing is what
happens here you have a right to an
attorney this lawyer has you don't have
a right to a specific attorneys lawyers
made sexual advances on me he's missed
misrepresenting my case he told me if if
I wanted him to do a good job I had to
let him give me oral sex he's had
doctors oh boy so defendants will say a
lot of crazy things to try and get their
way and I'm I'm guessing the attorney
did not make sexual advances I'm
thinking that this guy is just saying
whatever he can to get a different
attorney he's had doctors at Central
State Hospital put a false doctors at
Central State Hospital but a false
diagnosis on me okay I don't you know I
know mr. Wyatt pretty well and I don't
think he has the ability to make doctors
at Central State do anything well they
did it and he's the one that had me sit
down there well you know they may have
done it but I don't think that it he had
anything to do with it all right well he
won't give me the discovery well there's
things in discovery he's supposed to
give me the incident and told me that it
was the discovery okay they're
alternating comments that I wrote if you
want alright so here there's a ring of
truth in what the defendant is saying
the prosecution has an obligation to
disclose all of their evidence to the
defendant and that includes documentary
evidence that includes what witnesses
they're going to call against that
person at trial law gone are the days
where either the prosecution or the
defense could ambush the other side you
have to disclose all of that ahead of
time and so what this defendant is
claiming is that he didn't receive some
of that evidence and that he wants it
and if that is indeed the case it's
probably not the case because this guy
sounds crazy if there is something that
has been withheld
the prosecution needs to turn that over
to him all right so those are some of my
favorite legal TV shows I can see some
of those situations happening in real
life but others would get the attorneys
disbarred and probably get the judges
thrown off the bench if you enjoyed this
video and like to see more lawyer Reax
videos or hear about my law school
experience click on this short playlist
that I put together it includes my
reaction to some of the most famous
legal scenes in the movies and please
subscribe so you don't miss out on the
next video otherwise I'll see you in the
next one